hello everybody and welcome back let's
play crap here oh hello
what's that I see I'm seem to be out of
bullets so I'm just gonna trust this one
[Applause]
okay now where we left off I know where
I need to go but my safe point dropped
me a little farther back oh yeah go away
huh you're an a-hole hold your fist
chainsaw guy is open oh boy
why are there two stop do not enter
signs here we go Oh blood everywhere oh
there's a safe point in here scaredy
baby all right tough all right bring it
on
okay yeah I can take this all right I
need the nightstick anyway cuz I'm out
of woops sorry
there we go but then they're actually I
guess I'll just put this here cuz I
don't have any bullets for the pistol oh
this is gonna turn out nicely who
possibly lived here this looks like a
normal apartment besides all the blood
so face guy was normal at one point
probably I can tough it out what the
hell ah what the hell does it jump oh no
no I can't get back oh no oh no
oh no he always goes back to the same
place
day after day knows what she had like
yesterday but despite the fact that it
causes tremendous anxiety he insists on
returning
insists this which are Punic reasons I
remain skeptical
okay he doesn't respond and the
questions about his personal life about
that became extremely happened and I
much defense thrive but he insisted
describing us black day
he's called us online
topics discussing these feelings like
what just happened he told me the other
day
naturally I didn't take this year's
I saw no evidence to suggest this was
the case
playing educational okay Isis Simon is
crazy I think those like it's doctors
where the heck am I going what's going
on
freaking out man oh wow fine I was like
is that just an endless hallway or
something
died all got amount of memories
oh my god holy crap I wasn't ready for
any of that the dialogue was supposed to
fall down there my health I don't know
Oh bring it on you the doctor you sound
like a doctor I'm starting to piece
together an image here see I think
Simon's crazy the doctor that he
pictures in here is that guy is his
doctor real life for him in the insane
asylum trying to piece together in his
mind was actually happening naturally
and obviously if this whole thing is
just a nightmare in his mind
oh man that's spinning head I was not
ready for this bit again I'm okay I'm
okay
I am a okay I can do this
alright I need to get my gun out and I
need to actually hit them
nice smooth snores Lou
okay now wow that just now
so you still alive yeah that's my okay
hey hey whoa whoa whoa whoa hey hey whoa
whoa oh there's a door this door I'm
just going for the door he's going for
the door ah you know I don't have much
health one don't have much health he's
going for the door it's going for the
door going for the door still there ah
ah ah
close the door close it okay wait there
wait there
whoa check take it I got this just Boop
super juice
hellooo you guys are creepy close to the
end but now just let my health drops too
low without me noticing it what what
what
what what what what what
ketchup nice again two fuses my fuses
what got my first I probably shouldn't
give up my first my baton but I just
don't have the room I like this I don't
like this I don't like this at all guys
okay I got fuses but what the helm is
supposed to do with them
[Music]
so what Oh am I supposed to okay I guess
I go down like this where do I go what
do I do need a ladder to climb out again
okay I'm just gonna find a ladder he's
got to find a ladder okay this is where
I came in this is the first place I came
in let me check the basement area the
only place haven't gone yet I have like
no bullets to fight the ladies in white
[Music]
oh good German stop it Staubach can't
open with all this water okay oh gotta
be a way to shut off the water yeah yeah
oh the ladder inventory full up
balderdash okay okay
so I guess I'll pick up him into a
morphine later I imagine they're gonna
give me maybe an item no water monster
please know one of months one of us
okay I'm good I'm good all nothing I
guess cuz I'm so great
okay got the letter now I get the heck
out of here oh did I just need to come
into these apartments for that use what
was the fuse for I don't know I don't
know here huh come out okay okay okay
okay
I am a okay whoo
all right okay excellent
most excellent now go from here block
maybe doors that's the interest of the
apartment I don't want to go in ever
again no Bobby oh fast oh I hope I'm
going oh I didn't kill you guys
[Music]
old letter letter making it we're making
progress we're making it I hope I'm
going the right way maybe not but if not
oh well I'll just backtrack later okay
here we go save oh my goodness okay all
right that's all the time I got for now
so thank you guys so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
part
bye-bye